what's going on everybody welcome to
part 15 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this video we're gonna be
talking about its styles with matplotlib
so first of all what are styles so
styles with matplotlib are like style
sheets like you know cascading style
sheets with HTML it's a sheet where you
can kind of specify the style that you
want and like what kind of modifications
to your graph you'd like to make and
then you can load that style into your
graph and apply all those changes so you
would do this for the same reason you'd
have as you know a CSS sheet for HTML
because let's say every time you make a
graph you want the title to be you know
16 point font you want to use a
different font let's say and then you've
got you want your you know everything to
be colored that kind of dark gray color
that we were talking about before and
maybe you always want a grid but you
want a solid line you know these kinds
of things it might make the most sense
to go ahead and make a style sheet
that's specific to all those little
changes you like to make because as you
could see as we were leading up all
these little changes that we've made to
our graph have accounted for quite a bit
of lines and then what if you make that
change to every single subplot well
we're talking about like 200 lines I
know you don't want to do that so we can
use styles to kind of circumvent this
issue and also some of the pre-made
styles are actually really nice so let's
go ahead and get into that so first of
all the way that we use styles it's
pretty simple we just go from matplotlib
from the matplotlib import style that's
it next to use the style all we have to
say is style use and then we have to
specify the name of the style sheet
basically that we want to use so let's
say for example we want to use there's
one called ggplot okay so we're gonna
use ggplot let's use that one we bring
it up and now it's a slightly it's a
pretty different graph right we've got
the up and down colors still customized
and anything else we customize within
our script is gonna remain customized
but you can see that we cut it looks
like we're maybe using a different font
maybe a little smaller the the actual
axes has like the back
this gray and the grid is actually white
and so on another thing that we could do
actually instead of plotting possibly
just for now instead of applying the
candlestick we can plot yeah we can just
plot like so we can do a x1 dot plot and
date close P and we'll just comment out
the candlestick line for now we'll come
back to candlesticks but for now let's
just plot this okay so you can see like
a simple line looks like that you know
and if we were to plot maybe another
line we can basically plot you could
take this copy-paste close P and let's
plot open P as well or something so we
have two lines here okay so that's what
the graph looks like now without stiles
it would be quite a bit uglier there's
another style too that I kind of like in
it is five thirty five thirty eight I
think so
five thirty eight is another good one
let's run that one right so this one's
kind of an interesting one too we've
still got you know we've got some
overlap here's the font is much bigger
but this is an example of that graph and
you can see actually has no spines it
did kind of AXYZ color matches the
figure color and all that so it looks
pretty good
now what can we do styles and also how
do we find out all the styles so one
thing that we can do is to find out all
the styles that are available you can
print and print the PLT dot style dot
available and that will print to console
all the possible styles so basically all
of these now our Styles one I've made
but we've gone so got like dark
background was one and grayscale and B
mhm so let's talk show like dark
background this one basically makes a
dark background kind of chart like this
you know so you don't have to change all
this stuff right because to make the
dark background you'd have to change all
the spines to white all the labels to
white all to take things to white you'd
have to change every line to be this
like kind of like lighter pastel e color
and all that so as you can imagine
that's a lot of changes so that's how to
use like the the styles that kind
come with matplotlib but what if you
want to make your own changes to your
styles well you could use some of the
pre-made ones and you could work with
those if you wanted or you could go and
you can modify them in the script itself
so you can use the customization that
I've shown you guys or you can modify
them in the style sheet like you go to
the 5:38 style sheet and change it or
you can make your own style sheet right
in that directory so that's what I'm
going to show you guys next is how to
get there
so to get there what you're going is are
the styles that are available we can
leave that there but the next thing that
you might want to do is figure out like
where is where are these Styles like
located they're located in your
matplotlib directory but if you don't
know where that is you can always go
import well we've got we've got style
well we're not gonna find style I don't
think but we can like PLT let's say so
we can print and then print PLT dot
underscore underscore file underscore
underscore that should work right and
that gives you the the location of that
file so this is C colon slash Python 34
bow all the way to map plot live that's
the directory we're looking for is that
matplotlib directory so I have that up
so that's here so C 30 for loops I
packages matplotlib that's this path
right here that we just found by
printing that file then from matplotlib
we're looking for MPL data and then
style lib and then here are the styles
so we're using 538 right now so we can
right-click that edit with notepad and
here's that style so we can see that
there's some information here about the
author and where it came from and then
you've got the settings right line width
you've got solid cap style engined fancy
boxes being set to true these are the
colors so this is the color cycle so if
you have more than five lines it's just
gonna repeat by going back to this
original color so usually the first
thing I do is add a few more colors I
mean five lines is kind of a lot but you
know you can easily have ten fifteen
lines so you definitely want to maybe
add some more colors there so that would
be something I would modify 5:38 if
that's what I wanted
I would add more colors to it otherwise
you know you can modify the face color
to the axes you can modify all this
basically all this stuff here as you you
want or you could copy 538 and to make
your own style like I made our style
like this and you can put whatever you
want in there it can be even just a few
lines it doesn't have to be all the
Styles right you specify only what you
want to change basically so that styles
and it's just a really quick way to make
your your graphs look better oops like I
move my screen a little bit or something
anyway uh-huh
that's what you can do to kind of make
your graphs look a little better a
little more friendly and without having
to spend like hours changing what it
looks like you're doing those
customizations but it's so good to know
the basic customization options just so
you can change them on a whim and you
don't have to do because creating a
style sheet does actually take a lot of
work but it's just you know one and done
basically so anyways that's styles for
you guys if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time